filmmakers going to Sundance you say to
plan their distribution ahead of time
what would you have them doing six
months beforehand a month beforehand
well six months Brian doesn't exist
because you don't actually learn you're
in Sundance until I guess like two and a
half months before like I think you
learn about Thanksgiving so you've got
about two months yeah and it is like a
whole production basically the moment
you get into Sundance whether you're
planning your distribution or not
you have got a whole production on your
hands because you know there's so many
things you have to do for something like
you have to deliver so many different
things in our case with absolutely we
hadn't finished the film you know so
when we go in Sundance it was sort of
like okay we better finish the movie so
we better you know find some movie soon
some money to do color correction and
somebody can do the sound makes and so
on so we had all that so I would say
though for other people like if you're
if you're organized and planning it and
I think like if I was doing it again
like you know if I was submitting a
movie to Sundance and thinking we had
something of a shot of getting in and
started to think about the distribution
and I think no matter if we were getting
in Sundance I would be planning this
whichever festival we were getting a
premiere at you know a couple months I
mean you want him as I said start your
campaign from when you start making a
movie really start connecting an
audience building an audience for I
think it's absolutely fundamental now
and I think then obviously immediately
beforehand I would work with I would try
to find a theater Booker to work with I
would hire a publicist to work with
social campaign a social media
campaigner you know it would just be
like getting a team of people together
to work with and it's not I think this
it's just like making a movie you know
when you make a film you get all these
different people involved who are really
good at their jobs and you inspire them
and help them to achieve it and I think
you know it would be the exact same with
that model of you know distributing
you're not going to do everything you
need to find a team of people you know
you need to make a budget for that and
find a team of people who are gonna work
with you so you have less than a month
and a half once you get that call or
that email yeah you basically have about
a month and a half is that right to kind
of get your stuff in order yet
and it's over the holidays yeah no
there's no chaos no no stress so yeah so
what would you advise that you again so
you'd start finding a publicist you'd
find a theater Booker the the first
thing I would suggest is as soon as you
find out you then find a place an
accommodation where you're going to stay
because spike as the day's progress and
the week's progress the places of
accommodation within the Park City area
just they go up to an all-time high save
money so save money book early it's just
like buying an airline ticket save money
book early right and get your place
locked in make sure it's fully paid for
you've got a receipt free you've got the
keys the whole thing okay to go back to
distribution now and then from there you
want to make sure that you have your
publicist in line so that you've got
that online you've you've agreed what
she's gonna do or he's gonna do for you
and then at the same time your social
media wise you're really savvy now
you've got your Twitter account you've
got your Facebook account you've got
your your social platforms sorted out
and you're really talking about what's
happening day to day hour by hour on
Twitter building that audience and given
the anticipation that something is about
to happen really I think what I would
plan would be to be releasing the film
on a streaming service like vhx the day
after premiered at Sunday so if you're
like you know the very next day it's
available online for the same length of
the festival I would think I was into I
would plan it like that at first you
know so it would be like but the length
of the song that is festival you can
stream it you know for the same price of
a ticket you know so you go anywhere and
you want to see this movie the day that
it premieres that some premieres at
Sundance you want to see this movie
you're in Iowa you hit play just for a
limited time you know like have this
viewable for the same amount of time as
the festival you know and really build a
campaign
you know build audience for the movie
through that but then after the festival
is over then what what platform would
you suggest or then I would say like to
me if it's gone successful and by then
you'll have sort of like proof of
concepts in a way right you know after
the festival first of all you'll have
reviews you know from because and if
you're at Sundance you're gonna get
reviews from Hollywood Reporter and
variety and all the big you know so
you're gonna have reviews you're gonna
know how the movie is landing how it's
playing you're gonna see how people are
responding to it and so then you can
really plan it from there and I think
you'll have a sense of who your audience
is in a whole new way after that and
then you use that information and you
give that work and start theater
books and start planning a theater with
that information as a blueprint you give
that to the theater Booker and let him
look at that and go or her look at that
and go this is what we got at Sundance
this is what we had now yeah do you
think our audience because also from
that like if you've shown the movie on
VHS or Vimeo and demand you also have
like the Geographics from that you can
see where people have been downloading
your movie for instance so you can see
you know you can see oh my god all these
people in Washington DC wanting to see
our film great okay so give that
information to a theater Booker you know
let's go to Washington DC yeah
and retention rates and all that yeah
absolutely so I I mean I think that's
way obviously we haven't we you know
we're planning to do this with our next
film yeah you know we didn't do this
with helps Lydia as I said we were in a
like completely different head state so
it's gonna you know we're we're sort of
like learning all this stuff and looking
forward to putting into practice but
haven't done it yet well it was a
different landscape back into hold on so
it sounds like if you get the call if
you're good to go
get your room in our case we rented two
houses oh my gosh yeah and we had all
the cast and all the crew everybody in
the houses okay so get the place get
your publicist find your publicist get
that ready and know that he or she is
going to be there with you yeah okay and
then also get your online streaming and
and get that ready and habits and I
think you can take pre-orders for that
now so you can like set it up on vhx and
you could be taking pre-orders from you
know yeah Wow okay
and then once the festivals done then
find your theater Booker yeah and I mean
I I would suggest that you do that
beforehand to like I think like you know
bringing together that team and I don't
think you have to wait until you get
into Sundance to bring together that
team I would be like reaching out and
finding those people before you get the
call I think even if you don't get the
call you know you're gonna get the call
for another festival and you've got
those people you know who you're gonna
work with and you've got them excited
about the film you know yeah
so I would you know after I would like I
think find those people it's just like
finding your crew find the people who
are gonna be you know the ambassadors
for this movie
you